Besides the need for routing tables, the most important
thing to understand about the Internet is that it is
not run by any single entity, but by a
collection of thousands of autonomous systems that share information. Examples
of these autonomous systems or AS's for short include
Google, MIT, Georgia Tech, Comcast, and so forth. Each of
these autonomous systems is responsible for routing traffic within itself.
This is called intra-domain routing. And as you might imagine,
there are some interesting algorithmic problems here, that have the
shortest path-like character. You can explore this further by taking
a networking class, or consulting the links in the instructor
notes. Inter-domain routing, which is
essential to connecting these often regional
AS's together, gets a little more complex because of the
various business interests among these entities. They don't share all of
their routing information with each other, but they do advertise
their ability to reach public IPs with a protocol called BGP,
for Border Gateway Protocol. The essentials of such an
advertisement are the IP address that they're advertising that they
can reach. The Next Hop or the address of
the entry point into the advertising AS. And the AS
Path, which captures the sequence of AS's that a
packet along the route would need to travel through. And
AS receiving such a message would incorporate the information
into its own routing tables, so that it knows where
to forward packets. To take an example, suppose Comcast
wanted to advertise my IP address. Then it would
send an advertisement to its partners, which would include
let's say a level 3. The AS path on the
advertisement would just be Comcast's own AS number. And
the next hop would be the desired entry point, or
gateway, into the Comcast network. One of Comcast's partners,
let's say level 3, then might want to advertise my IP
address to say, the Apple AS. And so it
would send another BGP packet, with my IP address,
their gateway as the next hop, and the AS
path of level 3 and then Comcast. That's where all
this information has been incorporated into the routing tables.
All the routers in the Apple network know how
to send the data back to my machine. They
have their own internal routing before sending it to layer
3, who does its own internal routing, before sending it to Comcast, who
then does its own internal routing to get the message to my house.